Astor destroys many things including
illusions for example people assume
business owners are rich hardly in fact
profit margins are so thin one storm
could blow them over permanently
especially restaurants who are getting
hit hard these days by the time this is
over a night out we'll be heading to
7-eleven to buy beans we worry about
waitresses and servers and of course
every taverns ICU specialist the
bartender but to help them you got to
help the owners first it's like an
airline emergencies the parent has to
put on the oxygen mask before he or she
helps the kids the guy who owns the bar
needs help first so then he could pay
his staff if not you end up with boarded
up storefronts a bustling Street becomes
Skid Row towns die this way the solution
glad you asked I once balanced my
checkbook so president Trump if you're
listening I know you are first
government needs to make the loans
directly to the owner cut out the hiring
requirements and if the owner can't pay
it back it's on him or her they did this
after 9/11 and it worked the loans
should also have a long payback period
to reduce thoughts of suicide because
that's where debt can lead 16% of all
suicides are financially driven the
second part involves you the viewer you
need to go out and spend get that oxygen
pumping into the system but first you
deserve an incentive so how about for
one year we make meals and beverages tax
deductible take those bar tabs and mark
them all self entertainment so if your
family goes out and spends 200 bucks you
get 60 back later let's put the fun in
refund because if we don't you could
lose your favorite bar which sucks
because after all this you're gonna need
a drink you don't want I think that's
the reason why I think this is so
important is that when places that are
open at night close you lose the foot
traffic and then the street is just
empty and then becomes a danger zone
yeah it comes a ghost town I mean you
have you been driving around and it's
yeah it's it's shocking it's like well
where where is the life where is the
party yeah I'm all with you I just think
you know
we have to give consumers the kind of
confidence and the incentive to go out
and spend because they drive our economy
and make people aren't aware of it but
consumer spending is the prime engine of
the American economy I will say that for
big companies I think in a lot of the
big businesses want to reopen just you
have to understand that they also have
liability concerns if they bring
employees back in and then there's a
wave of infections or problems or even
people dying you know that then they
will be responsible so they have to
think about that as well and we don't
want as dr. Burks was suggesting in what
we saw in the a block there we don't
want to risk that we would have a second
wave comparable to the first way because
we have slowed down on the social
distancing hand-washing another
mitigation measures we've taken that
have proven effective right you know
Jesse you talked to President Trump
almost every day on that secret Batphone
yes stop next time you talk to him can
you plead with him to introduce a
deduction so people can get incentives
to go out and spend and also eliminate
all the hoops that small business owners
have to jump through let the owners sign
that lease and then the response I'm not
least alone and they'll be responsible
just cut out all the red tape I love how
Greg Gutfeld has made food and alcohol
the centerpiece of the economic recovery
package it is for me right off ribs and
and wine I mean that is that is gutfeld
right there in a nutshell I'm kind of
torn because emma has learned how to
cook during the pandemic so going out to
dinner is not as appealing as it used to
be but I'm gonna do my best and I'm
gonna go out as much as possible to save
this country just like I'm doing
everything to save this country now by
staying at home and watching television
yeah but in all seriousness though
there's this new test that they're doing
they're gonna roll it out in a couple
weeks
it's a post-exposure test you can prick
your finger in the comfort of your own
home and you see if you've been infected
with the virus if you have been infected
it's safer for you to go back to work
and your blood can then be administered
to people who are suffering and
as antibodies can help them recover and
that test I believe is going to drive
policy in terms of reopening the country
yeah you know Emily I think people have
a misguided assumption of the business
owner when they think you own a business
they think that you you're rich when
more than likely you're sleeping on
floors not taking a paycheck you know
these guys need help
absolutely um and actually you know you
and I talked about this before but I got
some comments just on my own family
small business oh that's that's a
privileged situation who do you think
cleans the toilets it's my dad
small business owners do everything from
top down to the bottom and you know I
don't I don't want to sound like a
debbie downer but the problem with the
payroll protection program one of the
major issues is that it doesn't align
with the reality of the situation facing
almost every segment of the hospitality
industry right and you know Jesse said
you kind of reduce it to food and
alcohol which obviously we love but the
reality is that is a 900 billion dollar
industry that's over 2% of our GDP so we
absolutely should do everything possible
to maintain it and also to stimulate it
and on Thursday the Treasury revised it
right they reduced the maturity portion
of the unforgivable amount of the loans
and also the limits on the forgivable
portion of the costs so that goes back
to what we were talking about before
which is that these small business
owners these operators have to spend 75%
of their costs on payroll but the doors
are closed there are absolutely being
gutted and many of them are appealing by
the way directly to their Senators
because there's no way that all of these
SBA you know that the websites and the
telephone lines they're totally clogged
and so they feel like who's gonna hear
me right now I can't apply for anything
it doesn't apply to me meanwhile other
applicable business owners don't even
they don't have that same cost revenue
but they also apply it's just it's
really sloppy at this point and I will
say that the tone in the hospitality
industry right now is one of panic and
devastation it is not positive and I I
again I don't want to be a fear monger
but just to highlight that this is a
very real situation that needs real
solutions you know I hate you
because that was a better monologue than
mine I have to say it was a you had way
more no you explained it far better than
I did Dana don't you do you miss your
bartenders and your waitresses and your
servers like I do yeah yeah well and
even other people like my dog walker
right even if it's great to have Jasper
here and everything but you she has a
business and they absolutely need help
I'm gonna add two other things I think
that the administration in the Congress
should consider here's one that's super
unpopular just to keep on the theme of
the week Greg I went to a capital gains
tax cut because if you want people to
pump money into the economy and buy
things and invest in things and help
with things well then allow people who
have earned some sort of return on their
investment to be able to spend that
investment and not be worried about it
being taxed to death the second thing I
would say is I think that they should
consider increasing the charitable tax
deduction for the next couple of years
because we know that there is a lot of
entities that need help I talked to a
family today that they run a baby pantry
out of their church and they're
desperate for help and so providing
people with means to be able to have the
incentive to also give would go a long
way I mean the government is already
doing a lot and I know that there would
be some on the left that would say how
dare you do that that would be just
helping the rich well actually people
with money can help actually get this
back on track and spend money at
restaurants and for the dog-walker and
buy your sister a nice outfit I guess I
just committed myself to that Angie I'll
be looking online for you tonight you
know you make a great point well wait I
just want to say Dana the people on the
lower rungs of the ladder are losing
more of what they have than people on
the higher end of the ladder who can
sustain it therefore it's a
responsibility of the people on the
higher rungs to spend a buttload of
money yeah so the people and the lower
rungs get it sorry one go ahead
absolutely no I think that's a great
point right but I want to spend some
money but
I was thinking boy those shorts that
Jesse had on in that PSA they're so pink
so wonderful
I just don't know Jesse you think you
can hook me up on I don't have them on
right here baby ha there you go